(upbeat music)
- Welcome to another
episode of the Addy Hour,
our first episode of 2022.
I'm honored and grateful
to be able to continue
in these conversations with all of you
and to be able to engage
with a lot of thought leaders
on really important topics,
which is definitely the case as well.
Before we jump in, I just
want start out and say
how encouraged I've
been the last few weeks
and few months honestly,
to have so many conversations
with so many of you
who've shared how you've
been using these podcasts
as resources for yourselves,
for family members,
for friends who've had questions
about different aspects
of mental health,
how that intersects with aspects
of our faith and culture,
race, and social justice.
So it's been really been encouraging to me
and also a boost to be able
to keep these conversations
as we engage in a lot of
these important topics.
And as I mentioned, that will
definitely be the case today.
I'm really excited and
honored to host Dr. Mays Imad
on a very important topic and timely topic
of trauma informed teaching and learning.
So by way of introduction, Dr. Mays Imad
is someone who is an expert in this area.
She received her undergraduate training
at the University of Michigan-Dearborn,
and then went on to
PhD studies in cellular
and clinical neurobiology
at Wayne State University.
Dr. Imad was on the faculty
at Pima Community College
for many years, has
recently joined the faculty
and is teaching at Connecticut
College at the moment.
And Dr. Imad's research really focuses
on stress, self-awareness,
advocacy and classroom community,
and how these aspects impact
student learning and success.
She's someone who is a
nationally recognized leader
and trauma-informed teaching and learning.
And she works with faculty
all over the country
and in her specific institutions,
across disciplines to
really promote inclusive,
equitable and contextual education,
which is all rooted in research.
So Dr. Imad is someone that
I definitely look up to,
especially with how she
continues to put mental health
as a top priority,
and is really helping us
within the education realms
to systematically support education,
the education of the whole student.
So I'm grateful to be able
to welcome Dr. Mays Imad
to the Addy Hour podcast.
Thank you for being here.
- Thank you for having me
and thank you for your kind introduction.
- Of course, it's a pleasure
and an honor in so many ways.
And again, as we're leading things off,
starting out the year,
for many who are involved in education,
primary and secondary
education, college education,
this is the start again of a new semester
or starting after the holiday break.
So before we get into the topic at hand,
just want to check in with
you, that's what I custom do,
and see how you are navigating
day-to-day at this point in time
as we get ready for another semester.
- Thank you for asking.
Surprisingly, I've been at peace
with whatever is happening
and the way it's happening,
and I say surprisingly,
because I recognize that I have
certain position and certain
power to advocate for change,
and sometimes I feel like
I'm just hitting a wall.
And so I would say the recent months,
I've been surprised to see
how much I'm just sitting
in the discomfort and learning from it
and even finding peace.
- Well, that's really refreshing
to hear in a lot of ways.
I mean, that's a topic.
I think a lot of us talk about often,
especially on our campuses,
encouraging our students
to be willing to sit in the discomfort.
So to hear you as a leader
and practitioner in a sense
who is saying the same thing,
I think also goes a long way,
but actually it makes me
think also it's a process.
I mean, the way you just described that,
even being surprised.
So even though you teach it in a sense,
not something that you necessarily
jumped into right away,
I mean, would that be
an accurate statement?
- Absolutely. Oh yes, absolutely.
I mean, I talked with my
students and colleagues
about the cortisol spike
and how to be careful,
and yet as I talk with
them about it, I think,
oh, and my cortisol spike.
So I know that it's difficult
and to watch myself lean in, I suppose,
or sit in the discomfort and
to just allow it to teach me,
I suppose, is surprising. Yeah.
- Now imagine not that
you haven't had that
empathy with your students
before and that authenticity,
I imagine that might even take it
to a whole nother level,
just what you described too,
in terms of how you talked
about your own experience with them.
And now that, again,
that you haven't talked
about that experience
in the past before,
but this sounds like it's
even in a different way,
in the current moment as well.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I, as you mentioned,
mental health is something
that is I advocate for,
I care deeply (indistinct)
something that is very much personal
and I see (indistinct) moral imperative,
it's a human rights issue.
And few years ago I was
working with a family member
who was dealing with that,
and the way I was very much tough love.
You come across a challenge, tough love,
you go through it, you
go through the fire.
Now, by the grace of God,
it worked for me, I suppose,
whether it did or not, who knows.
And so that's the
framework that I was using
with that family member.
And the person turned to me and said,
"Mays, tough love is not
working, it doesn't work."
And it was such a
profound humbling moment.
Almost gave me an
opportunity to pause and say,
"That's right, tough love is (indistinct)
And it's not always kind."
And so yeah, those opportunities,
those moments of contradiction
or (indistinct) or struggle,
or challenges,
they also present us with
opportunities for growth and yeah.
- Yeah, what a great way to say it.
And I mean, that sounds like
growth in the moment as well.
So we will have that
moment to pause and say,
"Okay, let me actually
hear what you're saying
and not just go into my
standard practice, so to speak."
And I think that's such a huge component.
And it reminds me of the
work that you're doing
in this space already on so many levels.
In that regard, I also wanted to ask,
for those who might not be as
familiar or familiar at all
with trauma-informed
teaching and learning,
if you could just define
that for our listeners
as a starting point.
- Yeah, absolutely.
So I like to start with definitions,
that way we're on the same page.
So I'm gonna take the word
trauma, and we're talking about,
in this case, psychological trauma.
And much like physical trauma,
something happens to somebody
and there is a reaction.
So whereas a physical
trauma, perhaps I trip,
I trip on a nail, I injure myself,
there's a reaction internally.
In a psychological trauma, an
event happens that I perceive,
and I perceive it in a way,
when I say, I mean my
nervous system, my body,
I perceive it in a way that's shocking.
It is overwhelming, it is threatening.
And as a result, our bodies, our brains,
are gonna try to protect us.
So there is a series of
reactions that will happen
in order to deal with that.
So what does that mean?
So for instance,
if I am on my way to work and I witness,
or I myself are involved
in a car accident,
our body knows danger,
and sometimes it can't
necessarily distinguish
between imminent and something
that happened in past.
And it will go into
this defensive mechanism
of fight or flight,
which is very physiological
and it will stay in that.
And so even though the event has passed,
the body hasn't quite
metabolized that event.
So then in a trauma informed education,
what that means that I, the
educator, I have that awareness,
that trauma is pervasive.
I mean, it impacts us.
It impacts how we show up,
it impacts how much attention
and energy we can pay
towards, for example,
solving a math problem.
So I, as the educator,
I have that awareness and
I also have the awareness
that there are things I
can do in my classroom
that can help the student feel
safe, connected, empowered.
Those are all really powerful ingredients
to, not necessarily heal
completely from trauma,
but enables us to get a
new start, if you will.
- That's a really helpful definition
and there's so many layers to it as well,
I mean, from the
neuroscience side of things,
to the awareness in the classroom,
to the practices as well.
And then it seems that there
was some clear neuroscience
tie-ins with your background
as a neuroscientist.
So I did wanna come back to the awareness
and practical pieces too.
But before that, I just
wanted to hear about
how you got into the work
and whether that was through neuroscience
or through other means, or a combination,
and how did this, I think
there are many in neuroscience
who may not necessarily
be as attentive to this
or thinking about it on a daily basis.
- I think it was a combination.
I mean, I always say I
am subject number one.
And I am a refugee.
I grew up in a country that was bombed.
I came to the country that bombed my home.
I experienced death at an early age.
I grew up in a war torn country.
Now, we didn't have the language
or the luxury to talk
about those feelings.
So in undergrad, I was,
as a philosophy major,
I was really fascinated by
why we respond certain ways,
why we do what we do and just
what makes us who we are.
Then in graduate school,
as a neuroscience student,
we really didn't learn
about trauma or emotion.
In fact, what I often heard
was that I'm too emotional
or I am a mental.
And I remember thinking if I could just
do something about my emotions,
I would be brilliant scientist.
So those are the, and I still
see those nuanced messages
in the academy, that emotions and thinking
are not compatible or emotions
are the antithesis of.
All the while I was experiencing
trauma and re-trauma,
the invasion of Iraq, my family is there.
And what was happening
is that it was impacting
how I showed up to classes,
to how I showed up to myself.
But I had no idea, it was,
even though ironically I
was a neuroscience student,
I was not connecting the dots.
And I would catch myself
saying, "What's wrong with me?
Did I lose my intelligence?
Maybe I'm lazy."
Maybe this maybe that.
Not making connections to
what's (indistinct) in life.
It wasn't really until I became
a teacher in the classroom
and I would catch my students
experiencing similar things.
Okay. They were not in a war torn country,
but they were DACA students,
they were first generation students.
They were displaced somehow.
And (indistinct) similar patterns
and I started having those aha moments
that how could they possibly
show up holistically, fully,
engage with the complexity of learning
and not bring everything else with them.
So I began really my work as
a way to help empower them
to pause.
Look, if you failed an exam,
it doesn't say anything
about your intelligence
and brilliance, and it
just that at this moment,
you have so much going on
and that impacts how you show up.
And so I started seeing
the impact on students
on students' sense of self.
And in that process,
I feel that it has offered
me some healing myself.
I started looking back and
remembering key moments
in my graduate (indistinct)
and thinking that,
oh, having empathy for
the traumatized student
who was stuck.
Yeah.
So, sorry that's
(indistinct) your question.
- That's a great answer too.
I mean, the personal component
is the way it helps you really tune in.
I wonder if that was, if it felt,
I don't know if it's the right word,
disenchanting at the beginning?
Because in some ways, hearing you talk,
I'm thinking about the research
that was already going on
in terms of the effects of trauma,
but how that likely was not incorporating
any of that into the classroom.
So, I mean, as a neuroscientist,
part of me thinks that
could be very frustrating
to see all this work being done elsewhere,
but not applied in a key
situation where it needs to be.
But I wonder, I mean,
did you feel like you
were building something
from the ground up in terms of awareness
or were there any others who,
I mean, it didn't sound
like there were many
who were paying attention to
it in this setting at all,
and just wondering what
your experience was like
as you were trying to bring
this to the forefront.
- I think what was happening,
I was doing it quietly with my students
because of (indistinct)
and because of my experience in emotions,
and I think generally speaking
in the scientific community,
it's been my experience
that we don't wanna deal with
emotions, they're sticky.
And so I was doing it quietly,
doing the research
quietly with my students.
And whenever I would speak
about it at conferences,
or I would see discomfort
as it's not how we were
trained, a lot of scientists.
But I did find
support from the K through 12.
So the K through 12 were
doing trauma informed
before it became something
in higher education.
And it was, yes, you are absolutely right,
it was frustrating because I
had the students' experiences,
I had my own experiences,
but also there was a science
that wasn't telling us
that, wait a second,
learning doesn't work in a vacuum.
And so frustrating because
I would go to conferences,
read articles, and I think,
why are we not talking about this?
I remember attending a conference in July
of 2017 and the conference had
many tracks, active learning,
metacognition, this
and that and the other.
And there was not a single,
and it was about STEM.
And it was not a single,
not a single session
about what's going on with DACA students?
Now for me, I was working
(indistinct) many of them,
and I could see that it was
the socio-political situation
was impacting how they show up.
And so for me to just go and say,
active learning, metacognition,
this and that and the other,
it doesn't take the whole
context into account.
There was serious trauma going on.
So yes, frustrating.
But when you're working with students
and you see how they respond
and how they give back,
it's worth it.
- Definitely in a lot of ways.
And I'm sure that you've
gotten that feedback
from students over the years.
And then just seeing,
I mean, I'm thinking also,
just as you described,
the empowerment from that as well,
just even that shift about
what you talked about earlier
with the (indistinct)
not what's wrong with me,
but being able to actually think back
about what happened to me
and how is that impacting
how I'm moving forward,
I mean, there's also a sense
of removal of blame in a sense,
and just having the
(indistinct) to move forward.
So, I mean, on that note,
what are some of the feedback
that you've gotten from
students and learners
as you've been engaged in this work
and really bring it to the forefront?
- Yeah. So one that has
been I think powerful for me
and also hearing from students.
So Dr. Addy, you're a neuroscientist
and you do this work.
We know that there are mechanisms
that are turned on or off
when someone undergoes trauma.
Now, there's research that shows that
it's actually the vestibular
system is impacted.
And the vestibular system,
it can impact our sense of being in space,
our sense of agency (indistinct)
So I've been fascinated
with that literature.
And also thinking about
when someone experienced
this trauma, our sense of
control or helplessness
feels shattered.
It's really important
to cultivate the space
or an environment where someone
feels they have choices,
option, agencies.
This has been really in terms
of feedback from students,
this has been one feedback,
I would say even more than
when they talk about safety,
the sense of I have a say, I have agency,
seems to be really powerful
in terms of helping students
feel that there is a way out,
there is a way (indistinct).
- And it's so important.
And it's helpful to hear what
has been kind of a salient
piece for the students from
their perspective as well.
On that note, if we can shift a little bit
to give people some of that practical,
I'm curious if you can share
how you encourage people
to bring that awareness
into the classroom as well.
Because, I mean,
I think that's underlying a lot
of what you've talked about,
that the awareness just hadn't been there,
maybe it had been in K through 12,
it had been in other pockets,
but not in a classroom setting
where there's really the stigma
of something that's wrong with you,
and it's more about deficits that you have
as opposed to what happens to you,
how do you shift or how
have you been shifting that?
- So I've been encouraging
people to read, learn,
listen about trauma, including
intergenerational trauma.
And my hope there is to
you become the subject,
you read or hear something, and you think,
"I experienced that."
And this I experienced
that can then help bring,
not just awareness about me,
but about who else is experiencing that.
And, so I tell my colleagues,
I tell family members and friends,
if you're doing the
laundry in the background,
just have something playing so
you could learn about trauma,
learning about the body. Why does it?
And the reason for that is not just,
I have awareness about
what happens in the body,
it's not an academic endeavor,
but it's really to help us then recognize
and have the self-awareness
when we're triggered,
what's going on, what
can we learn from that?
And then I say, what do
you think is happening
with the students?
There are things in the background
just like there are things
in the background for you.
So I start with that.
I have been really intentional to say,
"Learn about this, it's empowering."
We tell students, knowledge is power,
knowledge is empowering,
and knowledge can also be healing
because you listen and you
think for me, certainly like,
wait, there's nothing wrong with my brain,
it was just stuck because of the event.
And then I also encourage colleagues to,
on the one hand, I say, "How
would you like to be treated
if you were the student in that class?"
And more so I say, "Talk
with your students,
how do they want to be treated?"
A lot of times we make assumptions
that the students (indistinct)
that we care about them,
we have their back.
But when things get tough,
the brain will go into
this constricted narrow
and it may not be able to remember.
So let the students know that,
"I'm so excited you're in this class,
we're on a journey
together. I have your back.
I am invested in your success."
Repeat that so it can become part
of the DNA makeup of the class.
And then learn about the students,
learn about the human beings who are...
And learn in a variety of ways.
Perhaps a survey, perhaps email,
perhaps asking them to
come and meet with you,
learning about them will then enable,
I could give you a list
of do's and don'ts,
and I have suggestion to offer.
And at the same time, it can't
be a one size that fits all,
'cause context (indistinct) so important.
- Yeah. I think that's really well said.
And it makes me think about,
even as you were going
through your introduction,
just the way that you
are seeking to educate
the whole student.
So I love the framework of really
learning about them as well,
'cause it seems like also sometimes
there's a disconnect there
between maybe what an instructor's
deal that they're doing
or want to do versus
what students perceive.
'Cause I can imagine situations
where instructors may say,
just say things like,
"Oh, we care about how you're doing,
and we care about your success."
But it's all within the framework
of the academic achievement,
as opposed to caring
about you as a person.
And just to share, I mean,
this is all anecdotal,
not evidence-based per se,
but just the number of
students who share with me
in situations where we've
talked about their feelings
with everything that's happened
over the last few years
and students that have never had
any professor actually create
that space to hear how I feel
about the situation or
give a space to talk about.
So it makes me think about your comments
about asking how they're doing.
Whereas as an instructor,
an instructor may feel, "Well,
I gave those opportunities
by saying that I was invested in them."
But it's a disconnect between saying it
and actually taking a pause to
invest and hear the feedback.
So again, I'm sure there's a
lot you could elaborate on that
from the work that you've done,
but this is something I've noticed
just as engaging with undergraduates
and graduate students over the years.
- Yeah. And it is foreign.
I remember one time I asked my student,
"How's your heart?"
And he was, "What?
Physiologically, what do you mean?"
And I had to explain to
them what I mean by that
and why it's so important
to do that checking.
And I started like having a
variety of ways of approaching
and sometimes asking the question,
how are you? Is so tough.
I know that there are days
when you ask me that question,
it's overwhelming, I don't
know how to (indistinct).
And so I started for example
saying how bad is this Monday?
Or using emojis and actually,
a student recommended emojis.
But the point is, it's
modeling that you care enough
to allocate the time,
just like you did at the
beginning of this conversation,
asking where I am, how I am
and modeling and then
pausing to listen. Yeah.
- Yeah. I think it's so important.
I also appreciate the
sensitivity that you mentioned
in terms of the how are you
and how difficult that can be at times.
I've noticed sometimes people
also will give space to say,
"Well, it's fine if you
don't want to answer,
but I want to at least make
that option available."
'Cause even thinking back
to the last few years
with several of my students
of color in particular,
I mean, long before the
unfortunate situation
with George Floyd,
but just them often feeling
they didn't have the space
for anyone to actually check
in and see how they were
when these (indistinct)
things were happening.
So even if they didn't want to
share it, just to know that,
okay, someone actually
noticed and took the time,
then maybe I can come back to that later.
At least they felt seen
in that moment as well.
And so again, I mean,
it just seems like so many of the things
that you're trying to make sure
that those really come to the forefront
and there is that space as well,
which I think is critically important.
- Definitely.
- So I know you mentioned
not necessarily giving
all the practicals,
it's not cookie cutter,
even as you mentioned from
your tough love situation,
but other general practical components
that you do like to mention
to people who are in classroom settings
about what are some of the practices
once you have that awareness
to really empower the students
to make sure that it's at
the forefront and integrated?
- So let's start with options
and choices, voice and choice.
It's really important
for reminding student
that they agency, that
they have a sense of self.
So how would this work?
So I teach a physiology class.
And in a physiology class, I
assigned a research project,
and I pick the topic.
And it occurred to me a few years ago,
why am I limiting the topic?
If it's about what they are excited about
and what they feel connected,
why don't I offer a series
of suggestions and then say,
"And if you want to come up
with your own research question,
work with me, we will."
And what I saw when that
happened, when I did that,
is there was more
investment in the project
because now it's like,
now I have this kidney pain
that is like comes and goes,
I wanna research that,
versus the cookie cutter
one size fits all question.
So that's one.
The other thing is I have
flexibility is so important.
And so flexibility would
be we're in a pandemic.
I mean, I am so proud of the
students for just showing up.
It's overwhelming, we feel
overwhelmed, I feel overwhelmed.
Sometimes it's hard to get out
of bed and yet they show up.
And so we want to have
positive reinforcement.
So every class, I make it a point
to give positive reinforcement
to the whole class.
"You're here, I'm so excited."
Today I had a class and all
the students were there.
I thought I was in seven heaven.
So that positive reinforcement matters.
And at the same time,
let the students know that life happens.
And when life happens and you fell asleep
and you couldn't do the paper on time
because you were also, I don't know,
helping your father or
something, come see me,
we will work something out.
There is a tendency
among educators to say,
all students are gonna
take advantage of this.
And they're going to, I've
never, I've been teaching for,
I don't know, over 10 years,
I've never had a student
take advantage of it,
or even give me the sense that
they were taking advantage.
On the contrary, when I say,
"Well, do you wanna take an extension?"
They have like a little bit of anxiety.
"No, no, no, I'm gonna fall behind."
So talking about when
life happens, flexibility,
it doesn't mean the students
are gonna take advantage
or take you up on it,
but they know that there is that comfort.
So in addition to that,
I am really before COVID,
I'm really intentional to center
social and emotional and mental health.
So one exercise or one practice I do
is that during the first or the
second week of the semester,
I just talk very little about
social and emotional learning
or social (indistinct)
learning is holistic and so on.
And I also invite someone
from the counseling center,
either the counseling
center or a therapist,
and I have a conversation with the person
and I say things like,
sometimes I get really
triggered, what's going on?
Or sometimes I'm sweating
and I have anxiety,
what's going on.
And the person then, well
funny that you asked,
I'm so glad, and the person then gives
a layman explanation of mental health
and why physical health
we need to attend to it.
And then I have the student program
in their phone numbers.
Who do you text when you have anxiety
in the middle of the night?
There are free resources.
I wanna demystify it.
I want to demystify mental health.
I want to also (indistinct) it.
I want to show these students
that this is so important.
We're gonna have a session about this.
This is also to preemptively have a plan,
when things get really
tough, they have a plan.
Now, one thing I wanna say
about all of these things
is there's a lot that the
faculty member is doing.
They're doing their lesson plans,
they're doing their lectures,
they're doing their grading.
And also they're doing
these emotional giving.
And so it's a lot of work.
And what I have experienced
is that it gives back,
what do I mean by that?
When you look and you see
your students feel safe,
connected, they're
laughing, they're engaged,
you look at it and you
say, it was all worth it.
I am part of a tiny ripple effect
that is going to hopefully make an impact.
- I love that ripple
effect comment as well.
'Cause it ties everything together,
which you mentioned and
just the back and forth
that can come from that as well.
It makes me think also
what you talked about
how those things can have a
sense of healing for you as well
in your own process and
for us as instructors,
and it's really important.
- Yeah. I grew up in a tradition.
My grandma used to use a lot of poetry
and I grew up in her saying
that we're each other's mirror.
And the state of the students' wellness
and the faculty wellness,
they're very similar,
there's pain and anxiety.
And even in some cases,
romanticizing despair.
So I could look at the student
and see my own reflection.
And yet I could use the
power of the mirror neurons
to shift that (indistinct) back to me.
- Definitely powerful.
And I love that you tied the
neuroscience back in too.
(laughs)
One question was I've had,
and I don't know how much
of this is in the field,
which you started to touch
on all the importance
of the level of the student,
but just talking to,
thinking about my own kids,
talking to colleagues and their kids,
and thinking about all
the way through college,
just outside thinking
about all the stressors
that the teachers and
instructors are going through.
And sometimes again, this is
all speculation anecdotal,
but thinking that even those individuals
seem to be operating where the
stress is also affecting them
and how they interact in the classroom
and sometimes negatively
without maybe not necessarily
people being aware of it.
So I wonder even as you were
talking about mirroring,
are there ways that some of
that awareness can also happen
for instructors and for
teachers to be able to have
some of that self-awareness,
think about how they
approach their students
in the classroom, even as
they're trying to be attentive
to the students as well.
And obviously that's a lot to think about
in terms of cognitive load
and emotional bandwidth,
but I'm curious if that
comes into play in your work.
- Secondary traumatic stress is real.
We have a lot of the literature
comes from healthcare workers
and volunteers that work
with refugees and immigrants.
And again, because we're so
empathic, we are like a sponge.
And so we pick (indistinct) people's some
stress and distress and also
the helplessness feeling that,
"Oh, I wanna help the
student, but I can't."
And then it just, it
wears heavy on our hearts.
And in addition, we might be
having our own independence.
So they accumulate, and
then it impacts as you said,
how we show up.
And so I tell my colleagues, I say,
"Do this experiment,"
actually don't do it.
I mean, I don't advocate it,
but go to the class sleep deprived
and see how much patients you have
and then ask the students,
"Was I different?"
Of course, in fact, my students know
when I'm having a difficult day,
no matter how much I work to mask it.
So what that means is that
this whole notion of self care
is not just (indistinct) it's a necessity.
If I am going to want to
continue to give and support
and show up holistically for
my students, I have to pause.
I have to pause and
take care and replenish,
however that is for you.
- Yeah. So important.
And I imagine that sleep
deprivation experiment has happened
on several occasions.
(laughs)
- If I'm sleep deprived
and I show up to class
and actually, it happens,
it was so perfect the way it
happened that I actually pause
and I let the students
see what was happening.
They can ask me the same
question 3, 4, 7 times.
And I just repeat it and I make a,
hearted comments of it.
It was a day where I was sleep deprived
and they asked the same question,
and by the third time they asked it,
I had this, "What, are you kidding me?"
And I felt it.
And then I let the students
look at what was going on.
So it is important that we pay attention
to how the educators
are and to empower them
to take care of their own
wellbeing, to replenish.
And also parents, when I
speak with my family members,
I say, "What are you doing
to take care of you?"
So they could continue to
help their kids and yeah.
- It's so important and
encouraging to hear how you
incorporate it on both sides,
which again makes me just think about even
all the different things
that you're doing.
And just, I mean, in terms
of the research, the teaching
and helping your colleagues,
informing your colleagues,
helping your students,
And so I can imagine,
I mean, were there some
of your own practices,
if you're willing to share
just with everything,
because as you mentioned,
there's a lot of empathy
that comes with that too.
And it seems that it would be very easy
for you to be carrying out a lot.
I know I can say that from
my own experience too,
in a different space, but
as talking with our BiPAP
students and faculty, sometimes
all that weight can sit,
if there's not ways to at
least process and manage that
before the next event or
the next mentoring session
or the next teaching session.
So I'm just curious for you
how do you go about that
on a day-to-day basis?
- So I can't regulate what I don't know.
And so this self-awareness
is so important tuning in,
and I started paying attention to
I know where the pain shows
up and when I have not,
or when I feel I'm just really tense,
it's an indication 'cause I documented it.
I wanted to, if there is an
indication that I am just
going, going, going, no pausing,
no pausing, no processing,
no replenishing.
And then I just, I mean,
it's really interesting.
I think, let me just go one more day.
I'll take time this weekend
or the next weekend.
And it reaches a point
where for me, my body says,
"You're not gonna stop,
I'm gonna make you stop."
And it shows up in the form
of really migraine headaches
or tension headache or this or that,
where I'm no longer effective.
It doesn't matter how much (indistinct).
So what I started doing, I have
to hold myself accountable.
And so I have a group of friends,
family members that they check up with me,
we check up on each other and
we feel comfortable saying,
"I haven't been doing too much,
or what are you doing to
take care of yourself?"
And they can tell when
I'm not answering fully.
I also learned what helps me replenish,
and for me it's disconnecting
and it could be for half an hour only.
I remember a mentor saying
to me, "Take five minutes."
And initially I thought five minutes,
what is five minutes gonna do?
Five minutes, if it becomes a routine,
and it's just for you,
and you're just focusing on, I don't know,
breathing or dancing or
something, is powerful.
And so for me, every day in my calendar,
I allocate half hour and that half hour
I don't use the phone or the computer,
or I just, I do something with nature.
Even if it, I was in
Detroit visiting my family
and it was snowing
and I would practically
put every layer I have on
so I could go outside
just for half an hour.
And it was remarkable how much
it just helped me recenter.
So I could show up again and (indistinct)
to offer the space for others
to work through and move forward.
Yeah.
- Yeah. Such an effective practice.
And it's also (indistinct)
that's it's full circle
because it's the self-awareness
that you're also encouraging others
to apply in the classroom.
So sometimes when we are
trying to share insights
with others, it's difficult
to apply it to ourselves.
And that's also encouraging.
- I think it's important to
normalize those practices.
So not too long ago, I
went to visit my doctor.
Well, I had a doctor's appointment,
the doctor actually was
coming on her day off,
because I was in, and she said,
"Would it be okay with you
if we take three minutes to
just do a breathing exercise?"
And I said, "Okay, I don't mind."
So we sat in the office,
and we did a breathing
exercise and later she said,
"This is more for me.
I'm having an off day
and before I could give,
I needed to do this."
I felt healed before she
talked about my blood work.
I was like, I don't need to
know anything, I feel good.
- Wow. That's so powerful and encouraging.
I mean, I've never had
that type of experience
in a doctor's office, but
it goes such a long way.
And it makes it full circle
too, because I have had
students who have shared
that with me before,
shared that with other, like you said,
if someone comes sleep deprived
or there's something going on,
they're just not their
ultimate selves that day.
Just for them to hear that
from us goes such a long way.
And the way you just
characterized that story,
I think brought it home.
In a way that's hard to
sometimes conceptualize
when you're the one sharing those pieces,
but just to have yeah, that's amazing.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah.
I also--
- Continue to learn from each other.
- I do an exercise with students.
It's called a silent visit with yourself.
And so I talk with them
about just the nervous system
and how the nervous system
sometimes goes into autopilot
and so work, school and
then class, class, class.
And so what I do really,
it's a one minute exercise
at the beginning of the class, and I say,
take a minute to just
pause and remind yourself
why being here today is important for you.
And so, students they sit,
sometimes they close their eyes,
but they're there, they're present,
the whole thing's about...
And I had to miss class one
time and I told the students
there's gonna be someone who
will cover for me and so on.
And the students were not concerned
that I was gonna miss class,
they were concerned with,
what about the one moment, can
we still do the one moment?
And I was so touched that that
was so important for them.
And later on, I asked
them to give feedback,
and they said that really helped them.
There's something about
talking with their brain,
negotiating with the brain
that helped them focus
on the what's to come. So, yeah.
- Yeah, that's really encouraging to hear,
and it seems like the practice, it stuck.
In a way, maybe it was good for them
to be able to have you gone to say,
"Okay, well, we can also
incorporate this ourselves,"
even without you around.
Which I guess is a measure
of success for you as well
to really have it integrated.
Well, this has been so
refreshing in a lot of ways,
maybe in some surprising ways,
if people were tuning
in and thinking about
trauma-informed teaching,
not necessarily expecting to have
a sense of refreshing aspects,
and it was some of these practices,
but I think there's so many
things that are full circle,
things that we can
learn from our students,
and that can be vice
versa to really help us
all be in a better place holistically.
So again, that really ties
into what we do on the podcast.
I appreciate you being here to share that,
but did also want to close.
And I know you talk about
hope in your work a lot too,
just having you share what gives you hope
in the work that you do
and even as we continue to move forward.
- Yeah. Thank you, that's
a brilliant question.
I would say, yeah, people give me hope,
the students, their desire to learn,
their desire to do right
by their fellow students,
their honesty and compassion for me,
I talk about the classroom as a sanctuary
and it has (indistinct) for me
and the kindness and grace my students
have just given me over the years,
that gives me a lot of hope.
People are resilient, we are resilient.
Rumi says, "You are not
a drop in the ocean,
you're the entire ocean in a drop."
And we all are that, and we
sometimes lose touch with that.
And it's the community,
our fellow human beings that
remind us of wait a second,
I do matter and you do
matter. And we move forward.
So there's a lot to, sure,
there's a lot of pain
and trauma and anxiety,
and I will never undermine
it and grief and sorrow.
And at the same time,
there are pockets of
remarkable beauty and love,
and those give me hope.
- So well said.
In a lot of ways, ties
back to community as well.
I mean, just to being in a community,
to be able to engage and
have that sense of hope
as you see the students'
passions and enthusiasm,
and as you see their
resilience, so a lot of ways,
that's really encouraging to hear,
while acknowledging the
realities as well. So.
- Absolutely.
- Well, thank you again for
being here on the Addy Hour,
a very rich conversation,
which doesn't surprise me in the least,
and just grateful for the
work that you continue to do.
And just for the impact
that you're making,
I know that ripples are continuing
and they'll continue for quite a while,
and I'm excited to see how
things continue to move forward
for you in so many important ways.
- Thank you so much.
Thank you for the work
you do for advocating
for mental health.
And I'm really grateful to
have spent this past hour
with you and your audience.
- Likewise. So encouraging.
Thanks so much.
(upbeat music)